bonsoir anne sophie pellissier merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france vous êtes donc signataires de la
tribune pour quelles raisons bonsoir est
tout d'abord merci de ma vie tu es de
qui parle-t-on
on parle d'amazon amazon c'est un géant
du numérique que tout le monde connaît
je voudrais quand même parler de
souveraineté de souveraineté du
numérique parce que aujourd'hui nos
gouvernants on parle de souveraineté
numérique
et qu'at-il fait rien absolument rien on
voit qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
totale chez nos gouvernants
parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas il n'y a
pas de si vous voulez de courage
politique pour pouvoir créer cette taxe
kafa pourquoi j'ai signé cette tribune
pour plusieurs raisons un parcours des
idées de gauchistes de base mais
clairement pour plus de justice fiscale
par rapport à d'autres petits
commerçants mais aussi pour si vous
voulez des conditions de travail qui
soit meilleure et je veux penser à tous
et tous ses travailleurs et ses
travailleuses qui avec l'implantation
d'amazon et bien perdre encore leur
emploi aujourd'hui
voilà pourquoi j'ai signé cette tribune
mais si vous voulez si vous me permettez
une aparté tout ceci finalement nous
n'avons rien inventé
dans cette tribune je vous rappelle
simplement que le secrétaire d'état
mounir mahjoubi en 2019 disait déjà qu
amazon détruisait de l'emploi bruno le
maire souhaitait une taxe gafa
concernant amazon il a fait marche
arrière on le voit très clairement
aujourd'hui je rappelle aussi qu'il ya
eu une commission denquête au sénat qui
se posait déjà la question sur amazon et
rien n'est fait donc on voit clairement
qu'aujourd'hui ça marque une impuissance
de nos gouvernants à pouvoir mettre en
place quelque chose mettre une taxe à
ces profiteurs de guerre pour que à la
fois nos commerçants et bien quand même
le dire monsieur macron et puisse y
avoir du ruissellement
mais aussi qu'on puisse aussi m parce
que je n'oublie pas je suis avant tout
une soignante des moyens dans nos
hôpitaux
anne sophie pelletier vous dites voilà
ce sont des profiteurs alors oui ce sont
certainement
l'un des grands gagnants de la prise de
la crise sanitaire et économique amazon
mais dans le même temps il ya une grande
place qui est laissée vacante en a
interviewé beaucoup de commerçants qui
nous ont dit nous le click and collect
ben voilà on n'est pas des spécialistes
de la question on peut pas le faire et
c'est donc c'est vrai que quand vous
êtes consommateur
et bien vous faites appel à amazon qui
fait son travail qu'est ce que vous
répondez à mais vous savez c'est même
pire que ça
vous avez totalement raison il nous
avons aujourd'hui des commerçants qui ne
peut faire pas faire du click and
collect parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens adéquat pour le faire et vous
savez ce que fait amazon
elle permet par le biais de sa
plate-forme de vendre des produits de
certains commerçants
et vous savez ce qu'elle fait et bien en
tire aussi profit et la commission d'
enquête du sénat s'était justement aussi
pour voir les profits étaient faits face
à ce travail finalement gratuit je dis
quoi bein je dis simplement que
aujourd'hui on parle des commerçants et
si vous me posez la question est toute
façon en tout cas j'avais envie d'en
parler je pense que au vu des courbes et
au vu du discours de monsieur véran
peut-être qu'il est temps de repenser à
une réouverture de nos commerçants
évidemment en respectant les gestes
barrière en faisant très attention mais
vous savez nos commerçants ont fait des
efforts innommable
ils ont mis des moyens innommable pour
que justement dans leur commerce
il n'y ait pas une propagation du virus
donc si aujourd'hui je ne dis pas que la
bataille contre la copie d gagner mais
si aujourd'hui avec des courses qui
peuvent aller un peu dans le sens de la
de la descente
pourquoi ne pas réfléchir à une
réouverture et laisser aussi aux
commerçants cette possibilité de mettre
en place et bien des protocoles parce
que ils font les ingénieurs de terrain
et je suis persuadé qu'ils sont pleins
de bon sens c'est de bon sens dont on
parle aujourd'hui finalement mais
aujourd'hui que pourrait faire le
gouvernement justement pour ne pas
laisser
cette place à l'hégémonie de damas zone
puisque c'est vrai que plus savoir plus
on se rend compte que amazon prend
effectivement cette place puisque c'est
évident que fait le gouvernement mais on
voit déjà que bruno le maire a fait un
pas en arrière
il demandait il ya un peu de temps qu'on
crée une taxe exceptionnelle et on voit
aujourd'hui qu'il revient dessus
que peut faire le gouvernement est bien
il faut qu'il y ait le courage politique
pour imposer amazon quand on voit
qu'aujourd'hui amazon sur son chiffre
d'affaires il paye 0,04 euro d'impôt
on se rend bien compte que là il y à une
injustice fiscale donc c'est de la
volonté politique que de vouloir imposer
amazon normalement et puis vous savez il
ya aussi quelque chose dont on parle
très peu et qu'il faut aussi mettre en
avant
on parle de commerce mais amazon ce
n'est pas le commerce ce n'est pas que
le commerce en ligne finalement vous
savez ils ont aussi un monopole sur les
données personnelles
donc on voit tout ça que finalement ni
au niveau de l'europe même si la
commissaire européenne
margaret vesta guerre est en train
d'essayer de trouver une solution mais
de voir comment faire on voit qu'il
s'agit d'avoir une politique volonté
politique pour que ces profiteurs de
guerre soit imposé et que cet impôt eh
bien ils profitent à la fois aux
commerçants et quand on parle de
d'impôts parce que l'état a aidé les
commerçants
pas tous mais si on parle des deux
commerçants de l'état ça veut dire quoi
derrière c'est que qui va payer les
citoyens et bien c'est injuste c'est
injuste au vu des 200 milliards que vous
annonciez tout à l'heure ça n'est pas
encore aux citoyens de payer pour la
crise de que vides il y à amazon et
c'est à amazon de payer si tu es se
faire mais pêchent justement cette
volonté politique selon vous la peur la
peur de ce géant du numérique
vous savez au parlement européen ces
géants du numérique font pression aussi
sur les commissions ils font pression
pour garder leurs privilèges parce que
eux ont de véritables privilèges et
quand on aura véritablement la volonté
politique d'imposer ses gaffes à la taxe
caf a comme on l'appelle est bien là je
pense qu on remettra
l'église au milieu du village et là on
parlera effectivement de justice de
justice fiscale pour tous merci anne
sophie pelletier d'avoir été avec nos
députés européens de la france
insoumise merci à vous